merci et félicitations pour ton élection
mon cher nicolas
chers amis rapidement je voudrais
d'abord vous saluer et pour commencer je
voudrais simplement dire que ce conseil
national
il est un peu particulier tout
simplement parce que il va ouvrir une
période très particulière une période
cruciale pour notre mouvement avec un
point de départ et un point d'arrivée le
point de départ c'est la victoire que
nous avons emporté aux régionales le
point d'arrivée c'est bien sûr la
victoire que nous devons enlever pour
les présidentielles et il faut que nous
trouvions entre ces deux points le
chemin le plus court
évidemment qui ne doit pas être un
chemin au blick on ne devra pas marcher
en crabe pour réussir cette élection
présidentielle ce que je voudrais dire
en témoignant de ce que moi j'ai vécu
c'est que on ne remporte les élections
que sur ses convictions que lorsque on
affirme ce que l'on est ce que ce à quoi
l'on croit j'ai fait beaucoup
d'élections j'ai fait pas mal de
campagne
je ne ferai pas la primaire ça devient
une originalité et je peux vous dire que
celle-ci 7 est sans doute la plus
difficile la plus rugueuse la plus dure
d'une part parce que il ya eu des feux
croisés contre nous entre le front
national et le ps sur les plateaux
c'était une forme de marchepied à l'un
et à l'autre mais surtout la la gauche
est revenu à ses vieux réflexes
en outre étant de droite dure dès lors
qu'on voulait combattre la drogue dans
les lycées la droite dure dès lors que
on voulait éjecter les hadîths la droite
dure et cetera et cetera la droite dure
vrai vous dire que c'est pour la gauche
1-1 capacité 1 accs apa citant dirigée
contre la droite évidemment pour
nous tétaniser l art à tort d'ailleurs
de ne pas y recourir parce que longtemps
ça a fonctionné
mais chez nous en pays de la loire ça
n'a pas fonctionné parce que nous avons
parlé vrai parce que nous sommes restés
sur notre ligne parce que tout
simplement nous avons tenu un discours
sans outrance sans renoncement et sans
complaisance et je pense que ce discours
était le bon la preuve il nous a permis
de gagner et je pense très honnêtement
que la droite ce n'est pas évidemment le
front national c'est pas la droite le
front national - la sortie de l'euro et
de même que la droite ce n'est pas la
gauche - les 35 heures la leçon donc des
régionales c'est que on ne gagne que sur
ses convictions
vous enlevez les convictions il reste
plus que les ambitions il reste plus que
les combinaisons c'est exactement là où
en est aujourd'hui la gauche là où en
est le président de la république
évidemment avec une gauche qui est cul
par dessus tête qui ne pensent plus si
un jour on m'avait dit que la gauche
s'apprêtait à créer des apatrides en
france franchement je ne l'aurais pas
cru
une gauche qui ne décide plus je viens
dans une région où on annonce est un
vrai faux référendum le président de la
république a besoin d'un référendum pour
arbitrer entre son premier ministre et
sa ministre de l'écologie c'est
fantastique
après 160 décision de justice la france
est désormais un pays où on doit faire
un référendum pour savoir si on doit
appliquer la loi et c'est le président
de la république qui nous le propose une
gauche qui est une formidable machine à
désespérer les français mais surtout une
formidable machine à revenir en arrière
on a le retour de jean marc ayrault
on a le retour des écologistes et vous
verrez au train où ça va avant l'automne
on va voir le retour de christiane
taubira
voilà c'est extraordinaire voilà où on
en est à gauche françois lancé simple
pour lui la politique ce n'est que du
calcul
et bien mes chers amis puisque nous
devons débattre de la ligne la ligne se
doit d'abord être nos valeurs
ça doit être d'abord nos convictions
évidemment et si je peux rapidement dire
un point c'est que la première de nos
lignes c'est de ne pas confondre la
droite et la gauche
il y a une différence il y a plein
différence entre la droite et la gauche
évidemment
et s'il fallait caricaturer je dirais
que la grande famille de la droite et du
sens et l'enracinement et pour ce qui
concerne la gauche c'est plutôt
l'émancipation l'enracinement dans la
réalité l'enracinement dans l'identité
et pour conclure ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que il faudra répondre c'est ce
qui doit nous guider à une double
angoisse des français
le déclassement économique parce que la
france dégringole plus qu'aucun autre
pays en europe
voilà mais à côté de ce déclassement
économie qui a une autre angoisse qui
est ce sentiment de dépossession
culturel de dépossession identitaire et
les dieux les deux tiennent ensemble
évidemment et vous ne répondrai pas là
si vous ne répondez pas à l'autre les
deux se nourrissent bien évidemment et
il ne serait pas y avoir dans notre
mouvement
une ligne qui considèrent qu'on ne doit
être que économistes que la seule ligne
à tenir c'est l'économie bien sûr il
faut la tenir
de même qu'ils ne seraient pas y avoir
dans notre mouvement une autre ligne qui
considère que seule la question
d'identité est importante et comme on a
tout tenté sur le chômage ya plus rien à
faire oui on a tout tenté contre le
chômage sauf ceux qui marchaient eh bien
je pense qu'on répondra à cette double
angoisse par nos convictions avec une
équation qui me paraît assez simple
demain les réformes notamment pour
l'économie elles se feront si les
français ne doutent plus de même si les
français ne doutent plus de la france si
nous revenons tous ensemble un seul
peuple et non pas une juxtaposition
d'individus et non pas un archipel de
tribus c'est parce que nous serons un
peuple que nous pourrons demain
redéfinir et redessiner une nouvelle
perspective française bien évidemment il
nous faut reconstruire une amitié
civique y compris pour lutter contre la
barbarie et faire en sorte que nous
donnions à aimer la france la france
c'est notre patrie
france 2 d'être notre ligne la france
comme disait manuel levinas cette nation
cette nation à laquelle on peut
s'attacher autant par le choeur par
l'esprit que par les racines
alors oui voilà notre ligne merci de
m'avoir écouté
juste après le déjeuner vive les
républicains et vive la france